next day back in the polynesian town of
papatoy
they visit an expert who ids sharks by
their fins
so we were hoping to see if you could
look through some of your databases
shark scientist nicholas beret keeps a
photo archive of tahitian tiger sharks
that's cool and it's been growing
how many sharks do you have in your
database so in our database we have
around the
55 different uh tiger shacks but this is
new
for ten years i saw maybe two only right
now
since three four five years we have more
and more tire sharks
local divers send nicholas dorsal fin
shots
he enters them into the archive and
identifies the individuals
so you're looking at the strike patterns
he has a stripe when a
shark is growing they keep the same
stripe
all of the newcomers are females
time to find out if they have a match
this one here is kamakai and the dorsal
is pretty distinct she is mature so
there's
some scarring during mating
male sharks bite the females which is
why female sharkskin
has evolved to be super thick
[Music]
female tigers reach sexual maturity at
about nine years
there's no doubt kamikai has mated
clearly a big female tiger shark but do
you recognize her is she in your
database
i mean no no not not in my database okay
no
this one is uh i'm sure i don't know it
now they compare pictures from the
database
with the big females from the night dive
this is the biggest one that we've seen
there we were thinking possibly the same
shark
doesn't mean this yeah so this one i
think is not the same
andy and corey have just added three new
large females to nico's growing database
no that makes more than 40 large
sexually mature female
tiger sharks most with dorsal fins
chewed up and scarred
for mating looks like just a shredded
fin
everything points to a tiger shark
mating ground
an area with males must be nearby
so that means there's other hot spots
out there other places where these large
tiger sharks are hanging out
that haven't been studied yet if they
can find it
perhaps kamikai will be there looking
for a mate
[Music]
you